and that previous episode
just long enough for them to find out
what's going on please don't leave me
here just for a couple of days you'll
see time go by fast oh god she shaved
her head again Oh No
Oh what the CIA house girl is wanted for
treason she went out the window no she
didn't possible we're on the fifth floor
she couldn't go out the window
call it in that girl cannot get away
everything all right
oh so this is where the topic that okay
got it got it
how's the girl arrest - Parata welcome
back to yet another episode of beyond
two souls we're gonna continue from the
very beginning of the story of Jodie
where she was I know
well Miley did it why can't I do it
well [ __ ] alright what do we get
poor Jody yeah you better apologize
[ __ ] say something I don't know
how to tell you this Jody so I'm just
gonna tell you what your mom and I we've
been transferred we have to leave the
base what does that mean we really want
to take you with us but we think but
you're why everyone thinks that it would
be better for you to stay here with
Professor Dawkins dynamite main
of course we'll cash as possible when
you're better you'll join us in our new
home it's beautiful
so she will join them that's not gonna
happen it's for the best
it's obviously now what she wants
you can't just abandon your child like
that
be brave darling I don't this is
difficult
ago Susan just give me a minute film
yeah
[ __ ] sake
dick
it's enough come on [ __ ] is his problem
whoa I can kill him no I'm not gonna
kill him why can't I kill him I'm not
gonna kill him
no that's not gonna do any good at all
why would I even give you the option
that's so weird what are you missing
here
I'll always be here for you good dick
but it doesn't deserted I see daddy
Dafoe is he feel no faith and we are
going to the future so we're slowly
nearing the beginning if you boys
remember when she was speaking to
herself the prologue now we're going to
Navajo Navajo Navajo yes pretty sure
that's how it's pronounced i hadn´t
ain't pronounce yet whoa this is
beautiful it's gorgeous
we're in the desert Oh Navajo never die
we're way
what are we gonna get really exhausted
and thirsty and [ __ ] our so just play
nice and give me a break okay why are
you always so angry I am nice sad I
wasn't nice
I like your backpack see I'm nice I like
this place it looks cool it's very cool
we can use him what if we like ah
we can't it looks like a farm over there
we should check it out maybe that could
be some popcorns I love me some popcorns
oh no we're gonna do it
a fuck-boy even bothered at home what a
dick and hope it gets a bacon days leave
alone and the warm and palooka like a
boy alone in the eye here comes
Jay would you breasts pick up a
hitchhiker you know they could be
dangerous she's dangerous it's probably
not a good idea to pick her up
what what are you doing Jodi did I tell
you it's breaking it's gonna be okay
it'll live no we're dying of thirst and
everything's [ __ ] it's gonna be okay
how does she get there hey don't be like
that girl
I'm just fauna whoops sorry jeez I just
want to tell you about that place okay
okay I denied there's no reason to be
nervous
nah I'm not nervous okay cheese
it's all cool in the pool all right I
like this place I'm sure everyone here
is really nice they probably won't try
to kill me or do something bad okay they
probably will speaking from experience
of this game everything just what you
gotta appreciate the scenery using this
game I know I said water yes
see back in the old day you need to pump
water from a farm from the clam and
apparently we don't give a [ __ ] about
water anymore sir can I eat into it
I'm not allowed to go there apparently I
thought you were thirsty lying son ever
that matter looks like a penis I'm just
saying it so no one else says it okay if
I smell you can just tell me hey Jose
hey I'll see who are you darling
great to meet you my name is pepper God
have some more
i'ma take that as a no well what what am
I supposed to do
I thought you wanted water I didn't I
have a go what's in here people oh [ __ ]
it's like huh what the [ __ ] are you
let's go inside
oh yeah actually let's not gonna door
that's probably a smart idea that's what
I want I knew that you boys think I
don't know what I'm doing okay here we
go
knock on the door that is the weakest
knock I have ever heard
there's obviously someone inside Hey
I'm so sorry to disturb you I'm just
looking for some place to spend the
night and and I was hoping you were
helping why I can't stay here
sorry how about in the barn can I just
can I just spend the night in your barn
please I mean I promise I will be gone
by morning I told you you can't stay
here you need to leave now
no stay yeah yeah yeah esposo
I couldn't no noble names that I hate
I'd been a dosa batter it's very odd
okay it sounds like he's trying to speak
sweet okay you can stay here tonight
really why thank you sir
what's your name Jody I'm Paul it's up
Paul this is my son's Corey NJ my mother
my sake don't be surprised if she
doesn't answer you she hasn't spoken in
years
we're about to have dinner
would you like to eat with us yes thank
you yeah thank you
well that would better than expect them
holy Sh a can I sit next to you I don't
just so how the hell did she know that
what am i how did they know how did they
know she was coming
they just put out an extra plate just
because you never know that looks good
hmm I love me some corn hey you don't
look you don't look too happy grandma
groove something the matter
why the sad potato face yeah just help
yourself Jody
so no one's gonna say anything no one we
don't see many hitchhikers out here
can I ask where you're headed sincere I
just keep moving from day to day I keep
going long enough Oh figure out where I
met it I see
so what should we ask about the horses
do you breed horses yeah Mustangs we
also have a bunch of churros churros
sheep we sell their wool and milk it's
not much but it keeps us alive so alone
this is the first ranch that I've seen
in miles mm-hmm
there used to be more of us and you have
left for the city it's a hard life out
here well the food looks okay to me
that's Navajo guys are um oh yeah that's
where we are
right we're Danai
that means the people in that wall
that's what we call ourselves
huh the mostest
the monsters are coming you brought this
what
J Willa
them is but I want to eat my food what's
going on let's call it alright
are you coming uh yes that's one minute
stupid okay but what about all the food
I thought you guys had a rough life
you're wasting a lot of food for
you stay in your room no matter what you
hear what are you here what do you mean
you valued your life lock your door and
don't come out until the morning maybe
maybe the grandma has the power to maybe
that's why she stops faking maybe the
spirits are after her sweat maybe I'm
too smart for the game maybe we should
just go to sleep I'm staying
okay well let's go to bed
as I like to say bed way this is right
ways when the lamps say it shades our
down waves that's surprising work but
it's a very strange place
it is FRA don't worry I am worried
tomorrow will be a long way from you
good night
I won't be sleeping
well
stay in the room
huh no matter what you hear
what creepiest drinks name
Oh No
why are we going up what's a good watch
said the goal when she dare let us do
what the [ __ ] are you done what are we
doing Braz I am so confused
that's salt it's to keep spirits out or
ashes whatever demon lingo these days I
can keep up with what's going on I'm so
scared
that day
hey he told you to stay in your room are
we going out
let's go honey honey why don't you just
go find mr. right why I don't wanna help
I'm there you go
I don't want her to go on she'll just
get in trouble Jody why why do you old
UNS gotta cause trouble trouble trouble
yeah not gonna hurt dory that's not
awkward yeah
hello
is he not gonna open
always scared
can we go in this is kind of weird if
you ask me and I've seen a lot of ways
things in my days you know the hell is
he doing praying it's like [ __ ] that
[ __ ] I'm praying but he did say if you
value your life what should we do what
should we do what should we do is this
is just a visit get back in the room oh
okay all right there's no reasons for us
to [ __ ] around yeah now we're going back
in our room we do coke and a little spin
yep and then we're going back in our
room now the spin just to make it even
and and then a triple spin just so
people don't think we're drunk
and then we go back in our room
come on that's the most sensible thing
to do you cannot a denier to dieter that
it's not
try and translate Joanie you needlessly
what's gonna happen I don't like this we
did it
we done the little dazzling in fact I'd
say they weigh quite well actually quite
happy how that turned out yes
yes thank you what are you doing Jodi so
what do you guys think about this see
she has pants on and you don't don't you
think it's about time [ __ ] hell man
it's creepy I want to see chronic dream
make a horror game that'd be awesome
it'll be gmod rag dolls chasing it
around alright so is he the spirit that
they're trying to keep away she's not
gonna say goodbye maybe they're not
they're out on ready
he looked exhausted thanks told the boys
let you sleep thanks I really needed it
Coffee okay breakfast you resident
coffee i I like espresso but not a huge
fan of coffee I have my key
let's drug ourself with a lot of coffee
a lot of coffee coffee now let's get to
business sir no guess we're heading out
then aren't you gonna say something no
questions I'm gonna hit the road
thank you
there's a lot of work to be done on the
farm maybe you'd like to stay on for a
few days and helping hand couldn't pay
anything but uh never roof food on the
table what do you think
yeah
you'll find some more clothes in the
quarries room I have a reason why not
but did you know catch one I think it's
[ __ ] crazy
well at least we get some more
characters work I'm ready when you are
the sheep need water you can handle that
sure you got a vest that's adorable
hey grandma pump the water pump out like
that keep swimming swimming like that
and that's how you got one what where's
the sheep
how is she walking faster now how does
that even possible
what to tack this sheep what to mean
monster could have done something
sorry
you want water I don't think about the
sheep bottom water
oh here we go [ __ ] me and then Jenny
they pave yeah thanks Judy
you're welcome can you get some hay from
the barn I do believe I can we get some
hay from the barn
oh she's running now you go Jody sup
grandma hey wait your how you don't you
don't look too happy gramma
my name is Jody and I'm gonna stay here
for
hope that you don't mind don't touch
grandma what are you doing this is
beautiful did you make this yourself
let's get the hail ready jeez I'm pay
you to sit around and chitchat with
Grandma all day actually I don't pay you
at all
alright Hayes update but first we must
snoop around like any good video game
character yes
so these Harold
I thought Indians didn't take a picture
of themselves because they Billy as part
of their soul you are [ __ ] creepy man
stop at the door in the bait
how are you gonna carry that how about
you taking one from the top of course
let me do all the daring work I get it
bunch of fun
oh I'm sorry I'm sorry princess geez
their relationship is so [ __ ] and I
love the scenery it's awesome I actually
wouldn't mind visit a place like this
you know Carrie hey all day talk to
Grandma hey what's up lunch okay let me
just finish this first
yeah I mean I've been working for about
three minutes I think it's time for
lunch
sup sheep zone anywhere so where are the
Ducks in this place exactly
lunchtime go and join the boys if you're
hungry you coming later so that work to
do okay she has such a weird voice
it's like later then is it just me all
right she kind of talked like that I
like it that would this forgive me
thanks thanks so should we talk about
Novalis she's pronouncing it wrong there
used to be about 50 some years back or
no there's just us the others got scared
all the others decided to go live in the
city not everyone wants to live in a
desert
they got scared off by the spirit what
is this he mouths Ani true that your
grandmother hasn't spoken in years yeah
my father said she hasn't said a word
since my great-grandmother died that's
gotta be 30 years damn we talked about
the Sheep let's talk about the noise
what were those noises last night it
sounded like something was banging them
in the house and that's just the wind
it makes strange sounds in the desert
you lying son of a sheep I saw the dead
sheep what happened to them
a storm it wonder out of the pen and
choked to death on the sand yeah but
those are flesh you always have so many
questions do you always have a face when
I don't understand something
yeah how about if I started asking you
questions yeah yeah we ran from what
you're doing here you probably wouldn't
IQ huh so keep your secrets to yourself
don't ask any more questions
that's a good point you'll excuse me I
got work to do
yeah don't mind him Jody he's okay when
you get to know him
I'll bet well I guess I'd better get
back to her Paul get man see you later
God so hungry
what is it Joey Wong Jodie yeah you kind
of [ __ ] up Jodie but that's okay okay
[ __ ] grandma you want to hang out you
want to go to the hood pop some bottles
twerk anything hi anything else no maybe
the boys could use some help okay I'll
check where are they
maybe we get to ride some horses and
having like a connection time let's see
what chase just proud stubborn he never
wants to go in with the others do you
mind if I trip your horses before no
yeah go right ahead
a ski that sounds like ash combined with
broski just say he's a rookie don't be
afraid I'm just gonna come over there
okay she looks like it looks like Hitler
it's just me no way
this is between him and me you can't
down me what do it fine what are we
gonna do then easy easy boy
but what happened what am I supposed to
do it let's try and do it properly let's
just be careful hey Hitler I like your
hair it's fabulous hey des you want a
hug even the meanest people need hugs
see ya cheeky it's not so bad is it
a minute you kind of like me huh hey I
didn't ever dreamed of riding a horse
what it what it what are you proposing
Jodi what are you saying I had Jodi oh
he's gonna control that horse
Janey is take him to the inclusions ah
we're cheating this is cheating
hacks how'd you do that
ha ha ha
in your fight Seville misjudged you
maybe I had don't like your face and it
just ever just wants to take a shower
it's behind the bar
ladies first it's fine by me
and we had a pretty long hard-working
they think it's time to take a shower is
it here
this is the shower how does it work okay
go in Jody go and Jody
that's got to be [ __ ] cold actually it
might be hard actually nothing about
I know is he gonna creep up on her in
the shower what is it I don't like this
what hey I want the shower video crow
crow cry crown Chrome I'm actually glad
they don't show Titus it's so win in the
first game and anyway he was never seen
again
yeah good one
it's a bet
why do we have to lock up the house just
goody-goody yeah don't come out no
matter what happens
you remember the sheep last night I
don't want anything to happen to
should we persist for God's sakes Paul
what's going on here yeah we need to
know what's going on over to your room
there's nothing you can do
maybe it is I got super policy now at
least I finish the food good on you all
right well what do you boys think we
should do I mean normally I wouldn't do
anything but then since we got a super
powers and stuff like I am I like you
know you didn't catch anything about I
just said well you are a silly person
you have a nice nice size and t-shirt
yep
oh you're a girl well then you have nice
tits
well girls the girls can I teach you
soon I think am i doing it what
oh no that sheeps I just wanted to save
the sheep's she's actually going on huh
okay well see if I carry you just heard
what Paul said but we're careful
Paul says am i right
I like this press I really don't like
this this is not my decision
it is a pretty bad storm now damn look
at that [ __ ] isn't this kind of what we
saw in our dream Oh what
okay now so are those the ancestors
fighting it back
oh look what you've done oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
well I hope you happy Judy
[ __ ]
what did we do now uh I don't even know
where to go bow
Oh
how's close
oh snap oh damn you got us I can't see
where it's coming from
it's impossible that I can see how about
you use iDEN to help you
gosh I suck
hey you know sorry
it's too bright like a
I can't see it's [ __ ] too dark
okay shields oh nice
so they are actually good people those
things I thought they were bad for some
Thanks
Wow now you really look stupid Jodi
listen to me yeah
stayed in your room yeah have to tell me
the truth you have to tell me the truth
now so oh yes of course he wants blood
that's all he's interested in
we can't do anything about it you can't
fight a spirit well I can spirits don't
leave Elizabeth if he's here there's a
reason Oh looks like we're gonna have to
end the episode here but I hope you bros
enjoyed watching they like to be dead
helps me out of line let this guy come
to earth today I see you and your
beautiful place and the next time
somebody would say Sam eNOS is amazing